what is up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and mcu i'm your host warren
thompson and today we have some amazing
news about the marvel cinematic universe
and an upcoming project that i know fans
are going to be super excited for it
seems that an official nova project is
in development right now at marvel
studios looks like richard ryder is
going to be making his way to the mcu
and not too long from now i know this is
great news to many people we have been
talking about richard ryder nova coming
to the mcu for a very long time they set
him up quite perfectly in avengers
infinity war but we'll talk about that
and the support and breakdown everything
you need to know in this video about
nova coming to the mcu and of course if
you're new and you want to stay up to
date on the latest mcu news be sure to
subscribe and hit that bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos now
it did seem like it was only a matter of
time until richard ryder officially made
it to the mcu kevin feige had confirmed
that a nova project was coming a long
time ago and he kind of kept
reconfirming this over the years so we
knew it was coming we just didn't know
when but now things are looking really
really good especially since this
project already has a writer for it they
are actually getting writer sabir
prasada the writer of moon knight to
write nova and trust me when i say this
is fantastic because i've seen the first
few episodes of moon night and they are
great i'm pretty positive moon night is
going to be a lot of people's new
favorite marvel disney plush show not
everybody's new favorite because it is a
very different tone than our traditional
marvel projects but i think a lot of
people are truly going to love moon
knight and it is going to be at least
top 3 best marvel mcu shows now this
report is coming from deadline and if
you don't know deadline they are a very
reputable outlet they've been around for
a very long time they're very big and
very reputable and here's what they say
in their article today exclusive richard
ryder aka nova looks to be joining the
marvel cinematic universe as sources
tell deadline that marvel is developing
a nova project with moon knight scribe
sabir prasada on board to right so there
it is officially nova will be coming now
here's the thing the article goes on to
say that we don't know if it's going to
be a disney plus show or a film now
right away right now let me know in the
comments if you'd like it to be a film
or a disney plus show i personally think
that this could work either way there
are benefits to both doing a disney plus
show and doing a movie i'll use moon
knight for an example you can tell a lot
more story with a disney plush show and
for characters like moon knight who are
very complex and have a lot of story
that you need to tell in order for you
to understand who the character really
is and what they're going through a
disney plush show works great because
you can have six episodes or nine
episodes or however many you need to
truly tell the real story that's going
on that's a big plus to disney plus
however i would say that moon night
looks fantastic and i would have loved
to see a full movie on screen to see it
more cinematically now when i first
watched the first couple of episodes on
moon night i did them on my ipad and
then at the premiere we watched them on
a big screen and i thought wow this is
how everybody should see moon knight but
we're not going to be able to get that
and i only saw the first two episodes
that way and i wish we could see all
episodes that way so there are
advantages to movies as well plus with
movies they have a bigger budget and you
can bring other characters into movies
like the guardians of the galaxy in my
personal opinion should run into nova
and there's actually no reason why nova
can't be introduced before his tv show
or movie and i'll talk about that in a
bit but having a bigger budget is always
great as well so there are advantages
and disadvantages to both of them but
the deadline article goes on to say it
is unknown for now whether this will be
developed as a feature film or a limited
disney plus series as always marvel
studios president feige will produce and
in my opinion that's all you really need
to know right there as long as kevin
feige is the one that is producing this
disney plush show or the film we're in
good hands kevin feige has steered the
mcu in the perfect direction since the
very very beginning so i'm quite sure
the nova project is going to be
fantastic now based off of what we've
already seen in the mcu i think we
probably know a little bit about the
story and possibly the origin that nova
is going to have in the mcu there are
kind of two parts to nova story that i
think we could actually know and again
this is based off of what we've seen so
far and based off what is to come the
first part is avengers infinity war like
i mentioned in the beginning now when
the guardians of the galaxy picked up
thor after thanos decimated his ship
thor told the guardians of the galaxy
that thanos decimated zandar and he got
the power stone and to me this is the
start of nova we were introduced to the
nova corps in guardians of the galaxy
now keep in mind i am going to be
specifically talking about richard
ryder's nova because there is another
nova but we'll focus on richard ryder
now for those of you who don't know i'll
briefly explain kind of the origin in
the comics of richard writer's nova in
the comics when the last surviving
member of the nova corp raman day who we
did meet in guardians of the galaxy when
he is about to die he selects somebody
to give his power to and replace him and
he chooses a high school student in new
york richard ryder giving him all of the
powers of a nova centurion but little
instructions on how to use them now
that's basically what you need to know
so far as far as the origin story is
concerned because let's take that back
to what's happened in the mcu in
infinity war thanos decimated zandar and
the nova corps now during that time
there might be a final survivor who is
about to die it may be ramen day it may
be somebody else but i'm assuming that
before the last person in the nova corp
dies he transfers the nova force power
to richard ryder and this is how the
origin of richard ryder's nova will
begin in the mcu because it just makes
perfect sense it's already been set up
and again kevin foggy has been saying
that nova is coming to the mcu he's been
saying that for a while now so it looks
like the seeds have been planted already
for nova's entrance and it looks like
some of the seeds have actually already
been planted for him to make an mcu
debut maybe before his series or movie
comes out or the events that are about
to take place in the mcu are going to
set up his story and intro very nicely
in his own project deadline goes on to
say in their article nova first appeared
in a 1966 issue of super adventures was
a member of the intergalactic police
force known as the nova corps for which
he gained superhuman abilities including
enhanced strength flight and resistance
to injury while the character didn't
have many run-ins with some of the main
figures of the current or past mcu he
did have some battles with the scrolls
who have big parts in recent and
upcoming marvel projects including
captain marvel and the limited disney
plus series secret invasion i think it
would be perfect if you introduced nova
in the marvels or in secret invasion the
marvels actually makes a lot of sense
captain marvel has been traveling around
the galaxy it would make sense if she
ran into nova at some point in time and
of course as mentioned nova's previous
history with the scroll in the comics
makes for a pretty good entrance and
secret invasion as well if they want to
introduce them before now i also think
that guardians of the galaxy vol 3 would
be pretty perfect as well star-lord and
possibly the rest of the team is going
to want to go to zandar to see what
thanos did to see if anybody is left and
survived this may be where we run into
richard ryder because remember just
because the comics show somebody getting
the novacore richard rider on earth
doesn't mean that that's how it has to
be in the mcu it could be a zendarian so
it is very possible that we could see
him in guardians 3 plus not to mention
the guardians are going to go to at one
point asgard which is now on earth or at
least we assume we think they're going
to drop off thor back at new asgard
again but there is of course always the
chance that he could bail and perhaps
stay on a distant planet then somehow
get back on his own but regardless i
think that nova running into the
guardians of the galaxy would be pretty
cool but let me know what you think
about this super exciting news in the
comments down below how excited are you
to finally see nova in the mcu and how
do you think he should be introduced do
you want a disney plus show or a movie
let me know don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof